il a suffi de quelques secondes hier
soir pour qu'une douzaine de villages du
nord-est de l'italie et été rayés de la
carte
les images sont impressionnantes le 6
mai 1976 à 21h et pendant 50 secondes
la terre tremblait en italie la région
du frioul située au nord-est du pays est
frappé par un important séisme magnitude
6,4 sur l'échelle de richter
là ça commence à secouer je pouvais la
fin mais de grâce je suis sorti dehors
et quand je suis en dehors de moutons
par terre le séisme est ressenti loin
très loin jusqu'en autriche en france et
même en yougoslavie en italie jay mona a
été très durement touchée l'adil a subi
neuf secousses en quelques heures
seulement
autre exemple dramatique lui l' immeuble
non loin d'où dean où vivait une
quarantaine de familles et de vitesse et
non plus quitter à temps leur
appartement
on devait retirer ce matin les décombres
une fois centaines de morts parmi
lesquels de nombreux enfants
plus de téléphone ni d'électricité la
zone est coupée du reste du pays
très vite les secours arrivent ils
affluent d'italie mais aussi de
l'étranger
des lits des vêtements et de l'eau sont
acheminés par hélicoptère et cinq jours
après la catastrophe
même si les recherches continuent la
situation semble maîtrisée
cette arrivée massive de secours
commence à porter ses fruits
l'armée italienne a dressé les camps de
toile pour ceux qui avaient tout perdu
les moyens de communications ont été
rétablies et l'approvisionnement en eau
et en vivres et assurer le bilan du
séisme dans le frioul est très lourd au
total 9 189 personnes sont mortes plus
de 2000 ont été blessées et 45000 se
sont retrouvées sans abri
[Musique]